[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce 7 8 sociétés
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du manger
local les consommateurs se tournent de
plus en plus vers le circuit court vers
les producteurs locaux avec pour
motivation de mieux manger protéger
l'environnement ou encore préservé l sa
santé invité sur ce plateau bertrand
houillon vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonjour à vous
chargé du développement durable et de la
ruralité hervé givry également bonjour
vous êtes maraîchers bardon à magny les
hameaux je vais y arriver à retrouver
les places des uns et des autres et
julien castagnet qui est en charge de la
création de l'amap notamment des racines
et des graines sur sur elancourt elle
fasse avoue didier ouzou demi bonjour
vous êtes président jour mahb 100%
villepreux et laurence morel au second
vous êtes adjointe au maire de la ville
pr et on va parler notamment avec vous
tout à l'heure du travail que vous avez
mis en place pour créer l cette amap sur
villepreux on va parler donc des
initiatives du travail de chacun et puis
aussi et bien sûr de la pérennité
possible ou non de ce système mais comme
lors de chaque émission voici un nouveau
documentaire à découvrir mired une
bergère basque elle élève seule deux
enfants un troupeau de 170 brebis elle
illustre malgré ses doutes la réussite
d'une agriculture encore inscrite dans
le respect est des cycles et du vivant
un documentaire signé jane bourgon pour
san aussi production
etc
[Musique]
jeudi
je doute pas de ce que je fais
aujourd'hui même dans l'année parce que
je sais ce que ce que je vais produire
ce que je vais vendre ce que je vais
avoir comme charges à payer donc ce que
je vais avoir comme revenu mais par quoi
je doute parce que vu l'évolution des
choses de manière générale c'est très
très inquiétant et je doute pour
l'avenir je doute pour l'avenir proche
même dans cinq ans je me dis mais on va
faire comment ça va être dans cinq ans
la médina
[Musique]
à chauny
il sourit
[Musique]
ça y est
oh
[Musique]
de retour sur le plateau de télé 78 avec
nos invités du jour ils sont politiques
responsables d'amap ou encore un
maraîcher ils vont nous parler du
travail qu'il mène au quotidien et on va
débuter avec vous et hervé givry vous
êtes un maraîcher installé à la ferme
urbaine à magny les hameaux
c'est en 2013 que vous êtes reconverti
dans cette profession et janvier 2018
que l'aventuré a vraiment commencé
encore avoir parlé nous un peu de ce
parcours justement je suis parti en
formation en 2013 ensuite j'ai fait
trois ans de couze d'activité avec les
champs des possibles qui était avant une
association et maintenant qu'ils ne une
coopérative auquel je suis rattaché
puisque je suis salariée de la
coopérative dans mon activité
voilà et depuis le début de l'année je
suis effectivement à manille pour
produire des légumes pour la map
d'elancourt et de guyancourt légumes de
saison et bio c'est cependant sur des
lieux tout à fait oui oui c'est elle se
prend soin de ma reconversion si oui
pourquoi avoir choisi cette reconversion
aussi on dit souvent que l'agriculture
c'est c'est plus qu'un métier difficile
c'est mais c'est quelque chose qui vous
a c'était pour mettre en adéquation mais
mes pensées et mes actes voilà ça
faisait un moment que ça sa tournée au
maroc nous paraissait important de
passer à l'acte pour le regrettons pas
du tout bois pour enfin des tas de
choses et et je regrette pas du tout
nombre alors pour commercialiser vous en
avait parlé en cette production vous
passez par une amap c'est une
association pour le maintien de
l'agriculture paysanne et on a à lui en
cours y en aurait une prochainement
encore à elancourt je viens castanier ou
comment ça fonctionne une amap déjà une
amap c'est
le cd adhérents des personnes qui
souhaitent se réunir en sang pour
soutenir maraîchers ou une agriculture
locale vous fait avoir aussi bien du
pain on vous pouvez avoir des heures
voire même de la bière dans le coin vous
avez des gens qui qui produisent
localement et qui produisent plus haut
de préférence
il ya une demande de plus en plus forte
de la part du consommateur oui et
davantage de l'amap c'est que vous êtes
en lien direct c'est à dire que le
consommateur et le producteur
il n'y a pas d'intermédiaire entre les
deux vous êtes toujours en lien direct
vous développez actuellement la map la
future amap sur elancourt alors c'est
pas une amap c'est une association avec
elle est créée il y aura possibilité
aussi aura des points pour voilà pour
les consommateurs qui veulent retrouver
les produits par exemple quand
exactement
nous ce qu'on fait c'est que on a un
lien sur lequel tout est notifié
notamment comment bougent toutes les
semaines de lieux de distribution ils
soient au courant
nos adhérents sont courants où ça se
passe il ya une autre amap représenté
ici en plateau c'est 100% ville pour
vous elle vous nous en parler nous en
parler pardon tous les deux mais tout
d'abord bertrand au lion vice président
de saint quentin en yvelines en charge
de la ruralité du développement durable
expliqué nous un petit peu le rôle que
le politique à jouer dans ce
développement que ce soit des fermes des
lieux d'agriculture ou encore des amap
quelle place le politique peut-il
trouver dans tout ça les collectivités
aux enfers rôle à jouer aujourd'hui sur
le retour et la diversification de
l'agriculture dans le cadre de
l'aménagement du territoire dans le
cadre de l'accompagnement des
installations et et de la dynamisation
aussi en local sur la mise en relation
des
des habitants avec les agriculteurs
surtout dans une dans un contexte aussi
contraint en termes de foncier que les
l'île de france très concrètement
aujourd'hui pour l'installation qu'un
agriculture un agriculteur une
agricultrice s'installent sur des
nouvelles terres dont qui est à acheter
ou louer des terres quand on sait la
pression foncière qui existe dans nos
secteurs
c'est quasi impossible si la
collectivité n'intervient pas en mettant
pourquoi pas à disposition des terres en
louant des terres elle même en remettant
des terres à l'agriculture c'est à dire
en les urbanisant pas aussi derrière on
ne favorisera pas la diversification de
l'agriculture
il faut savoir que sur un territoire
comme saint quentin en yvelines on est à
90 % de terres en céréales aujourd'hui
pour faire 2-1 pour faire revenir ou
raccourcir les circuits sur la
consommation pour les habitants en
direct on ne mange pas que des céréales
en clair moment donné il faut aussi
diversifier cette agriculture et c'est
pas aujourd'hui pour le moment sur les
terres céréalières qu'on arrive à
prendre donc il faut qu'on prenne sur
d'autres terres le travail des
politiques et a été nécessaire l'aide
des politiques pour vous pour votre
conversion pour développer votre votre
espace agricole ou encore pour la map
oui et non au début au début non on se
débrouille tout seul et au final oui
puisque pour l'installation je suis je
vais aller m'installer à magny les
hameaux qui votre commune également je
leur précise vous en êtes le maire a où
il ya un projet justement d'installation
de plusieurs agriculteurs voient là et
il ya actuellement la construction d'un
bâtiment pour pouvoir stocker les
légumes le matériel en fin de compte
puisse se travailler dans des conditions
correctes mais bien sûr saint quentin en
yvelines récemment il ya eu un séminaire
sur le manger local justement je vous
propose de revoir ce reportage que nous
y avions consacré le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines est composé à 21%
des espaces agricoles à l'occasion du
séminaire du manger local une convention
annuelle d'objectifs a été fini on est
sur un objectif de pérenniser
l'agriculture qui existe déjà sur le
territoire de l'aider à une
transformation vers plus de local de
conversion aussi
beaucoup plus de respect
en terme environnemental et aussi donc
quand c'est possible de pouvoir
favoriser les installations pour une
diversification 32 exploitation agricole
interviennent sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
mais certains agriculteurs sont entier
espère beaucoup de ce séminaire en
présence des acteurs locaux
on vit dans une région où deux on voit
l'organisme prendre du terrain agricole
et mais a contrario nous on a du mal à
faire nos bâtiments
je veux de la pérennité et de la
confiance parce qu'on n'est pas là pour
juste d'être là deux ans et demi trois
ans et puis après faire autre chose ou
laissés en abandon cetc des projets de
vie qu'on met en place et ça à leur
faire comprendre aux acteurs locaux
c'est je m'aperçois que c'est très
compliqué clément produit une
cinquantaine de paniers pour la map
local 100% villepreux qui a pour
vocation de soutenir l'installation des
agriculteurs dans leurs activités
on a plus de 115 119 famille qui est qui
et qui viennent qui se fournissent par
ce biais là tantôt comment dire sous
forme de contrats hebdomadaire tantôt
sous forme de contrats bimensuel les
amap association pour le maintien d'une
agriculture paysanne permettent une
vente directe sans intermédiaire entre
le producteur et le consommateur 100% du
montant du panier est reversée aux
paysans le 7 8 sociétés se poursuit avec
aujourd'hui cette thématique autour du
manger local on a entendu parler et on
vous a vu dans ce reportage également
sur la mappe de villepreux
quelle a été la motivation déjà pour
lancer la map comment ça s'est passé il
y avait une volonté politique et vous
avez aidé ou celle inverse
il sait
déjà c'est pas un hasard que ce soit ça
se soit fait à villepreux nous amusons
nous avons un territoire qui est très
majoritairement agricole 65% de la
commune est en terres cultivées donc
ceci explique cela
déjà aussi ont bénéficié d'une situation
où il y avait énormément de bio sur
l'ensemble de l'agglomération on est à
peu près à 8 % de terres en bio à
villepreux on est à plus de 22 % et ce
depuis plusieurs années déjà
donc on bénéficiait de sa est en fait
par un hasardeux des circonstances j'ai
rencontré deux jeunes agriculteurs qui
venait de s'installer sur la commune
et là tout de suite je me suis dit qu'on
tenait quelque chose un filon parce que
c'est une ville qui s'agrandit on est
passé à 11500 et bientôt treize mille
habitants je savais très bien que les
familles voilà il ya vraiment un goût
pour pour ses circuits courts pour
comment dire manger local manger bon et
donc quand ils m'ont expliqué tous deux
que il souhaitait vendre uniquement via
des amap je leur ai dit écoutez banco
pour lunel était déjà en activité elle
avait être produisez des oeufs bio donc
je vais simplement demander si elle
avait encore un volant de production
disponibles ce qui était le cas donc en
fait la première rencontre a eu lieu en
février 2016 et les premières
distributions de à l'époque on faisait
ça dans des commerces de la ville qui
nous prêtaient leur leurs locaux
de façon très gratuite ça permettait
aussi de faire connaître des commerces
de la ville
et ça a commencé je crois au mois de mai
ou juin 2016 donc ça s'est fait très
vite et pour le 2ème agriculteurs ça a
été plus long parce que lui il était en
phase d'acquisition de terres donc sur
la commune et là vraiment comment à dire
les adhésions des amapiens et le soutien
financier parce que dans le système de
la map ce qu'il faut bien expliquer aux
gens c'est que en amont de la récolte
des paniers les adhérents règle
directement à l'agriculteur l'ensemble
de leurs contrats annuels ou donc voilà
il paye d' avance donc c'est bien pour
ça qu'on dit que c'était pour le
maintien de l'agriculture paysanne parce
que pour eux c'est vraiment une
pérennisation de leurs voix lasse et
leurs rentrées financières sont sont
sécurisés donc grâce à ça même s'il
n'avait pas encore produit ça lui a
permis de passer au travers des fourches
caudines je dirais d un des bancs de la
safer et on a vraiment accompagné moi en
tant qu'élus et puis après l'association
qui s'est créée parce que c'est vrai
qu'après sur le territoire c'est grâce à
des bénévoles que que l'association
fonctionne au jour le jour mais disons
que ce qui est sympathique dans une amap
c'est que vraiment c'est la conjonction
c'est le point de rencontre de
différents dynamique ya la dynamique des
consommateurs des des clients on va dire
consom'acteurs on dit maintenant il y a
la dynamique des des bénévoles de
l'association
il ya les agriculteurs et il y a les
politiques et en fait comment un gars
quand tout ça se conjugue nous on a eu
un petit alignement des planètes mais
dans ce cas le résultat justement pour
pour la map jusqu'à présent sur
villepreux parce qu'il est ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est mieux le post quoi
dans cet amas possible peut-être
préciser mais pour l'instant ça c'est en
train de se développer donc là bas c'est
quand même le travail du du maraîcher
qui nous font 10 des légumes
on a aussi donc florence morlière qui
nous fournit du miel des fruits rouges
et des oeufs
ah que tout récemment donc on a fait des
contrats avec un meunier boulanger donc
ça c'est assez extraordinaire c'est
quand même assez rare parce qu'il se
trouve qu'il ya des départs 7 céréalière
qui sont déjà cultivées en bio depuis
des années et ce jeune meunier boulanger
donc qui est aussi une personne quittant
reconversion achète le grain fabrique
lui-même sa farine et ensuite fait son
pain donc il ya presque deux villes de
blé de rien et on est vraiment on est
vraiment hyper local et après ça
n'empêche pas que il y aura d'autres
d'autres possibilités sur le territoire
y est aussi un producteur de pommes et
de poires donc voilà tout ça c'est tout
un tas de choses à développer mais qui
sont extrêmement chronophage pour les
bénévoles
il ya un échange entre les amap qui sont
proches les unes des autres par exemple
louis s king aucune concurrence je sais
pas on s'est passé pas en concurrence et
généralement on travaille soit en
interne amap sur certains sur certains
sur certains gros dossiers par exemple
les collectifs qui sont montés qui
s'appelle ce qui pousse c'est différents
acteurs qu'ils soient adhérents de
différentes associations même des
des personnes même sur des gros dossiers
on peut travailler on adéquation et une
volonté aussi de s'élargir à peut-être à
d'autres agglomérations aussi de
développer ce système là d'élargir un
peu vers versailles par exemple ou pas
trop on reste sur des circuits courts
mais du côté des martyrs c'est des
actions citoyennes qui qui se met en
place
il existe déjà d'autres amap autour de
notre territoire
j'en connais une par exemple sur le
plateau de saclay proches forcément de
là où j'habite chevaux magny les hameaux
mais il y en a d'autres un petit peu
partout c'est en train d'essai mais ton
mieux maintenant le la plus grosse
difficulté pour pour ce système
finalement de lien entre producteurs et
et habitants c'est de trouver la
production mais de trouver maintenant la
diversité de la production
on a un certain nombre de maraîchers qui
se soit installé d'autres d'autres
producteurs qui qui s'installe par
exemple aujourd'hui pour trouver de la
viande bovine dans notre secteur c'est
plus compliqué pour et puis ensuite pour
trouver ne serait-ce que dec ça devient
compliqué aussi puisque on n'a pas les
productions nécessaire les productions
nécessaire pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
répondre aux besoins des nos
consommateurs qui sont qui sont ici donc
c'est toute cette cette diversification
alors il y avait un mot pendant le
séminaire qui avait été donnée par par
un professeur de l'agro paris tech et
qui est la densification de
l'agriculture cette densification c'est
tout simplement sur un même territoire
d'avoir plus de productions plus de
diversité de production pour pouvoir
mieux répondre justement aux besoins des
habitants et là c'est un vrai enjeu
aujourd'hui on parle donc dû manger
local j'ai tout de même préciser qu'i à
ce guide qui a été édité par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui permet de retrouver
justement les adresses des amap
rencontré à les maraîchers aussi les
producteurs locaux vous saurez à qui ils
sont ce qu'ils font et où trouver leur
production je redonne ces quelques
chiffres à saint quentin en yvelines
la 21 % des terres sont agricoles 32
exploitation l'a15 amap ça représente 28
emplois locaux tout de même possible le
souligner on va parler aussi de la
pérennité tout ça juste après ce
reportage consacré à un autre maraîchers
c'est robert pirès lui aussi est
maraîchère magny les hameaux et lui
aussi s'est reconverti en 2014 et nous
étions présents lorsqu'il avait livré
ses premiers paniers de légumes
reportage le terrain a déjà bien changé
en ce début du mois de juillet robert
pirès cultive salades choux raves
courgettes ou encore tomates en février
dernier ce maraîcher avait vu son
installation prendre forme avec l'aide
de plusieurs bénévoles
cinq mois plus tard il propose déjà des
produits
je crois tout le monde est content pour
moi en tout cas je le suis et les
retours que j'ai des gens aussi dans
l'ensemble ils aiment ils aiment le goût
des culs des légumes
donc ça ça tient pas à moi c'est ça veut
dire que la terre répond bien
ils ne sont pas gros mais légumes parce
que j'ai un j'ai une problématique
d'arrosage très limité mais du coup le
goût lui il est pas mal et on est assez
content et la quantité
je crois que c'est bien aussi
actuellement robert pirès fourni deux
amap l'une à magny les hameaux la
seconde dans le xviiie arrondissement de
paris
il livre une quarantaine de paniers
chaque semaine on vote un peu lapin mais
moi j'aime bien j'ai démarré de manière
précaires on va le dire pour pouvoir
démarrer vite j'arrose soit l'arrosoir
sur des surfaces cultivées soi ou
uniquement et donc je ne peux pas
beaucoup arrosé je ne peux pas beaucoup
mouillé mais plan mais
mais du coup c'est quelque chose qui
pour l'instant je les remarques qui est
gérable même même depuis plus d'un mois
où il n'y a quasiment pas eu d'eau
simplement ça ne me permettra pas de
grandir la surface exploitée pour
augmenter mais le nombre de paniers et
en faire quelque chose de rentable en
quelque sorte qui permet de tirer un
revenu
actuellement vous vivez de votre
exploitation pas non non parce que je
cherche d'abord en fait à pérenniser
mon activité c'est à dire donc j'achète
ce dont j'ai besoin
donc aujourd'hui mes revenus sont
entièrement réinvestis dans ce qui est
dans ce qui est à chat dans ce qui est
un investissement sûr d'une sur du
matériel plutôt du petit matériel
mais quand même donc aujourd'hui je
cherche pas forcément à en vivre en tout
cas prendre pour cette année et puis
j'ai démarré en milieu d'année ce qui
n'est pas là les complète mais c'est
vous dire que vos portières en autisme
pour améliorer la gestion de l'eau un
chantier pour acheminer celle de la
ville va être lancé d'ici la fin du mois
de juillet robert pirès cultive pour le
moment près de 8000 m² de terrain sur
l'année il faut proposer une quarantaine
d'élus de 80 d'art y étaient différentes
le 13 mai dernier et livré pour la
première fois la madeleine du poil
[Musique]
c'était émouvant il ya quelque chose de
d'émouvant dans cette dans cette
première distribution
parce que les légumes sont là parce
qu'ils se sont arrivés il avait même
plusieurs semaines d'avancé avec avec la
chaleur et je suis très content de
pouvoir pouvoir fournir un beau panier
pour pour cette première distribution
aux amapiens de manille et châteaux
forts une cagnotte solidaire avait été
lancée en février par l'association le
bonheur est dans le pré 4600 euros ont
déjà pu être récoltés ce prêt a
notamment permis à robert pirès
d'investir dans un tracteur dans cette
aventure le maraîcher n'était donc pas
tout seul un élan de solidarité qui
l'encouragent à poursuivre son activité
contredire aujourd'hui veut complètement
épanoui dans cette reconversion je me
pose pas la question tous les jours
heureusement mais moi je je crois que je
suis heureux première donc de voir la
l'installation d'un maraîcher sur magny
les hameaux la discussion qui se
poursuit en plateau est justement à
hervé givry je me tourne vers vous vous
connaissez sans doute un robert pires
qui travaillent pas très loin de chez
vous on travaille ensemble
donc c'est rsa reste de très près je
vois qu'on parle de la pérennité tout
ces exploitations aujourd'hui vous êtes
reconverti vous êtes installé on et vos
marques
il est inquiet pour l'avenir où vous
vous dites que ce système va durer le
système va durer mais il faut toujours
trouver des nouveaux adhérents parce
qu'il ya les lui il ya du tour ne
meurent tous les ans ça se comprend il y
en a qui sont pas satisfaits y en a qui
déménage voilà donc il ya du
renouvellement à faire tous les ans et
tant que l'on n'a pas la totalité des
contrats signés
on se pose des questions bien sûr pour
les agriculteurs pour les maraîchers
aujourd'hui il est possible de vivre de
ce système durablement ou un système de
circuits courts système damas de bien
sûr moi j'étais j'étais en formation
chez un maraîcher qui marchait très bien
pour lui et puis on a il y en a d'autres
en ile-de-france pour qui ça fonctionne
mais si le temps de lancer la machine on
va dire moi je commence je suis un
débutant et donc du coup c'est pas
encore tout à fait installer d'ici là
qu'on vous dit que vous êtes un débutant
ça a été difficile d'aller dans les
champs le premier jour non pas du tout
non non c'est un plaisir il n'ya pas n'y
a pas de souci mais voilà c'est ça ne
changera changement de vie est
effectivement fauveau faut s'adapter
mais c'est avec plaisir des plus en plus
tout de même néanmoins de demande
combien d'adhérents dans les différentes
amap justement déjà sur sur votre
secteur et puis après celle de villepin
nous on doit être 35 je pense juste en
juste pour les pour les contrats
maraîchers après comme c'est une
association la différentes choses
ça fait très très vite s'est montée en
charge très vite là on est à 103
on va sûrement arriver à 150 d'ici dix
lits mais avec des adhérents qui reste
il n'y a pas trop de turnover il ya de
plus en plus d'hommes bape pour
l'instant on sait par la firme va
l'amener dans nos premiers six mois mais
d'après le sondage que j'ai faits auprès
des adhérents
il y aura peu de turn over et on a
beaucoup de gens et les systèmes ce
système
comment dire comme c'est qu'on ne
pouvait pas intégrer les personnes
volontaires au flux 2d semaine tout au
long des années en fait on clôt les
inscriptions après l'agriculteur calculs
ces semences en fonction du nombre de
panique il à fournir et puis après ils
ré ouvre les inscriptions quand et donc
pas pendant cette cela passe de temps et
des gens qui continuent eux à s'inscrire
et donc nous par exemple on a des listes
d'attentes vraiment très très important
il après c'est vrai que c'est rassurant
pour le maraîcher à voir des jeunes
réalisateurs
celui ci s'est jamais des jambars taux
moyen aura d'autres qui disent et moi
j'ai déjà ces temps de commandes
expérience dans une autre amap ailleurs
et je dis qu'il faut être vigilant face
à la map d'être vigilante parce que
c'est quand même une économie qui est
assez fragile et et l'important n'est en
fait que s'il faut absolument que ce
soit de donnant donnant on va dire vous
vous achetez votre panier mais d'un
autre côté il faut que le maraîcher
puissent vivre décemment de sa de son
travail quoi c'est les sorties de la
charte des amap d'ailleurs et justement
les particuliers au niveau des tarifs ou
mais ça coûte
c'est quoi c'est très intéressant parce
que dans la mesure où vous sauter un
intermédiaire commercial l'association
elle n'a aucun comment à dire elle ne se
prend aucune marge sur les paniers en
fait donc en fait les gens adhèrent à
l'association la plupart du temps c'est
une dizaine d'euros à l'année et ensuite
le règlement que les amapiens foncé en
direct
vers le producteur donc nous si j'en
juge
notre expérience nous quand les
personnes viennent de récolter leur
panier c'est l'équivalent à chaque fois
de deux grosses cagettes de légumes donc
il ya en moyenne me 15 15 à 18 kg de
légumes en bio et chaque panier
le tarif qui a été fixé par
l'agriculteur est de 23 euros alors
montrez moi une enseigne aux préfets
ainsi donc c'est pas seulement un truc
écologique voilà pour les faits nous n'y
a que cela partir du moment où elles
font l'effort c'est vrai et d'une de
payer en amont ça c'est un premier
effort et le deuxième effort c'est aussi
le côté participatif mais
personnellement je trouve aussi que
c'est l'aspect sympathique de la chose
c'est qu'il faut aussi donner de son
temps c'est à dire que ça fait partie de
l'engagement de la personne qui souscrit
il va falloir qu'elle participe à des
distributions qu'elle aide à constituer
des paniers tous les packs
consom'acteurs donc et pas uniquement
consommateurs nous laissent aussi
comment dire je conseille à toutes les
personnes qui ont un petit coup de mou
dans cette période de l'hivernale
d'aller à une distribution de damas
parce que c'est formidable vous discutez
avec votre producteur ça a du sens quoi
je dire de tout de suite de savoir à
bastien il ya moins de
carottes là maintenant pourquoi et c'est
directement le producteur qui vous
explique pour quelles raisons et si et
ça on a beaucoup de familles qui
viennent avec leurs enfants c'est ça a
du sens c'est aussi pour ça que vous
avez fait cette cette démarche en tant
que marché c'est aussi pour avoir du
contact avec elle et les consommateurs
échanger avec eux bien sûr c'est
important
moi je suis toujours à la distribution
de toutes les semaines pour répondre aux
questions sur la et puis on a expliqué
un peu ce qui se passe les aléas
quand il y en a et puis pour les enfants
aussi parce que moi aussi j'ai des
enfants donc c'était c'est un ensemble
de choses là épargnés parce que je
pourrais rajouter aussi ça met plus en
phase les gens avec le le l'évolution
des saisons parce qu'on voit on voit ce
qu'on veut quand vous êtes en vie sous
vous êtes un peu hors sol vous vous
rendez pas compte du changement de temps
oui là vous voyez que là on est dans la
période de 8 des panais après il y aura
des carottes après il y aura des courges
les gens et les légumes correspond à
quelle saison les enfants si on découvre
des légumes ou si oui andy roddick ou
des légumes et puis en même temps à un
moment donné va falloir qu'on apprenne à
se dire que en plein hiver ici dans
notre région on mange pas des tomates et
que des tomates ça pousse pas saoul en
cellophane
dans une cagette dans une barquette en
plastique voilà même bio voilà un moment
il faut aussi revenir vers la réalité
des choses
parfois c'est un peu dur moi meme je sui
adhérents de l'amap depuis depuis
presque dix ans maintenant
la première année quand on se retrouve
avec des des blocs de terre des choux
l'hiver bon ben voilà on change un petit
peu son mode de consommation
mais c'est aussi la responsabilité tout
le monde et c'est juste la réalité des
choses et ça en connaissant directement
les producteurs ça permet de revenir sur
ces réalités
il nous reste juste quelques minutes
avant de conclure cette émission et
j'aimerais revenir sur une thématique
dont on parlait juste pendant que le
reportage a été diffusé et vous attirer
mon attention sur le fait de
l'attribution des territoires et vous
avez rebondit juste derrière aujourd'hui
la complication c'est quel territoire
quelle taille de parcelles pour quelle
agriculture on met dessus et là il ya le
politique qui a un rôle à jouer
voilà en fait c'est vrai que
les terres actuellement sont
majoritairement des terres céréalières
ou avec des productions oléagineuses et
ce sont des terrains du coût des
parcelles qui sont relativement grande
or dans le cas d'une attribution à un
maraîcher ou un arboriculteur clairement
les surfaces souhaité sont souvent
moindre et donc cela oblige à faire des
division parcellaire et c'est la safer
qui opèrent ces division parcellaire et
c'est vrai que à ce niveau là je pense
que les politiques ont vraiment tout
leur rôle à jouer pour favoriser cela
parce que c'est vrai que ça ça fait du
coup une une commande ya une agriculture
plus vivante plus comment dire certes
avec des lopins plus petit mais ça veut
dire que chaque lopin va être comment
dire attribué à un maraîcher un
agriculteur donc ça fait vraiment une
agriculture de proximité on parle
d'agriculture périurbaines beaucoup plus
dense et beaucoup plus peuplé voilà
c'est c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
vraiment accompagner et sur lequel vous
intervenez aussi en tant que politique
c'est c'est tout l'objet du plan local
de développement de l'agriculture locale
et des circuits gourou qu'on débute
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est tout l'objet aussi de mon
engagement à saint quentin en yvelines à
savoir de réussir déjà à pérenniser les
agriculteurs qui sont déjà sur le
territoire céréaliers ou autres autre
type de culture qu'il puisse y avoir un
certain nombre de conversions de terre
vers une meilleure prise en compte aussi
l'environnement mais qu'on puisse
favoriser cette diversification alors il
ya un certain nombre d'outils qui qui
existe qui doit être utilisé mais la
base c'est le politique qui s'était
guère qu'à partir du moment où on a des
terres qui sont publiques
derrière c'est nous donc en tant que
citoyens qui devront maîtriser ces
aménagements et qui devront permettre au
fil du temps d'avoir ces transformations
de territoire pour avoir cette fameuse
densification d'agriculture qui puisse
répondre aux besoins directs des
habitants et relocaliser finalement la
production est essentiel aujourd'hui
merci à tous les cinq d'être venu
témoigner échanger sur cette
problématique du manger local je
rappelle ce guide qui a été édité par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qu'on peut retrouver auprès de
leur service et puis sur leur site
internet
aussi c'est la fin de ce sept huit
sociétés à revoir sur tv soixante dix
huit points comme et puis sur notre
application mobile à très bientôt
[Musique]